ready for this oh yeah let's do this
[Music]
this is a wicked blade kind of scared of
it and your
blade the ida
awesome
the ida is a long cutting sword most
commonly used by the europa people of
west africa their idolization of ogan
the god of metal and war led their
blacksmiths to be among the most skilled
in west africa with its leaf-shaped
blade that could be single or
double-edged the ida was a practical
tool for both agriculture and hunting as
well as a deadly weapon on the
battlefield in combat it was often laced
with pepper or poison to paralyze
enemies and ensure that the slash of the
ida left many dead in its wake
this is a kill test
to see how lethal your weapons are i
will take your weapons and deliver
multiple slashes and hacks on these
ballistic dummies let's do this
[Music]
[Music]
okay josh
this is a wicked blade
on the initial hack right here the blade
went all the way through into the ribs
and broke those ribs the other side same
thing that would disembowel this dummy
your weapon
will kill
thank you good job thank you very much
mareko you're next you ready i'm ready
let's do this
well morocco it is sharp as you can see
what it did it lacerated right in all
the way to the chest cavity breaking the
ribs that are in there on the horizontal
slashes same thing it lacerated deep
feels good balances out and your blade
will kill
good job thank you
next up is the sharpness test
to test your double-edged sword i will
take your weapon and deliver three
slashes per blade across this web of
ropes if your ida is sharp it should
meet no resistance
joshua first you ready let's do it let's
do this
[Music]
i'll tell you josh
this is definitely sharp it meant no
resistance cutting through the ropes it
feels good in the hand your sword sir
will cut
good job thank you very much appreciate
it
all right morocco you're my choice you
ready bring it on let's do this
[Music]
well morocco your blade is fast it's
light it did last away through some of
the ropes and some of them it didn't
overall though your blade will cut
thanks doug
next up is a strength test
dave
gentlemen to test the strength and
durability of your blades i'm going to
chop into these femur bones three times
now the point of this test is not to see
how many bones i can break but to see
how well your blades hold up through
that punishment
josh you're up you ready i'm ready all
right
damn
everything stayed straight
everything stayed tight but you can see
we've got some extreme chipping on that
blade
did sizable damage to what we were
swinging at but you can just see those
those chips
all right morocco you ready
yeah
all right
i did my best to make the geometry so it
could withstand this kind of use but
seeing the damage that happened to
josh's sword makes my heart like sink
down in my stomach
[Music]
well morocco you did pick up
that slight bend
but your edges are beautiful
they've held up quite nicely
nicely done thanks
josh moreco it was definitely a battle
but there can only be one champion the
judge's pick forest and fire champion is
[Music]
marreco congratulations you are the
forged and fire champion good job
wow congratulations please buddy
that's a beautiful piece but with that
coarse grain structure and the brill
edge your sword just wasn't able to hold
up in the strength test and that's why
we gotta let you go now i understand
josh
please surrender your weapon
i feel they made the right decision
i may not be the fortune fire champion
but i'm still a great bladesmith and a
better dad but i showed my kids that you
step up and you do it again and you give
it your best and i think i did that and
i brought a beautiful sword looks nice
but uh
looks don't cut
marko how does it feel rising to the top
earning a check for ten thousand dollars
and being the judge's pick forged in
fire champion yeah it's definitely been
a serious challenge but uh to be able to
represent for doug a man who i respect
very much and to make it to the end and
win uh that makes me really proud
i came so close to winning last time it
feels really good that i was actually
able to pull out the win this time
winning the ten thousand dollars it's
gonna be so helpful for myself and my
family doug your horse won the race i
hope that i made you proud so thanks for
bringing me back man
[Music]
the cabio fleecer
both functional and ornate the fleece is
the traditional sword of the cable
berbers of north africa ranging in size
from daggers to sabers over three feet
in length fleeces are single edged a
straight back and cutting edge that
tapers the long needle-like tip and
unusual weight and balance make it ideal
for tearing through male armor commonly
worn throughout the 19th century the
fleecea was deeply rooted in the
berber's faith and is complete with
complex geometric designs and animal
head pommel
this is a kill test to see what kind of
lethal damage your weapon will do will
deliver slashes and thrusts on this
ballistics dummy
colin you're up first you ready have fun
let's do this to help me today i'm
bringing back one of marcato colley's
chief instructors please welcome u.s
staff sergeant chris bans
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right colin your cabil fleesah is
very sharp on the initial thrust it
penetrated deep and easily through this
whole ballistics dummy the handle is
comfortable it's easy to slash in and
thrust out overall
it will kill
good job
thank you sir all right daniel your turn
you ready yes sir let's do this
so
all right daniel your weapon is wicked
sharp
on the initial thrust it penetrated deep
and on the way out with your belly being
forward it lacerates out easily
now
because you have such a very skinny
handle right here and there is no pummel
with a counterweight all the weight is
in front the balance just makes the
blade rotate with a small handle like
this but in terms of damage
it will kill thank you good job
all right bladesmiths next up is a
strength test
ben blade smith to test the strength and
durability of your kabul fleecer i'll be
smashing them into these terracotta pots
edge first remember this test is all
about where the parts do to your blades
and not the blades due to the parts
caroline you're up first you ready yes
sir all right
[Music]
awesome man
well colin the blade held up beautifully
the uh edge
it's like it never solved their terra
cotta did a great job well done thank
you sir daniel you're up you ready i'm
ready
[Music]
[Music]
well daniel your edge held up pretty
well i rub my fingers across i can feel
just a little bit of uh a wire edge but
nothing major but my my big concern
this handle
it's so small that i had a tough time
indexing it but it's beautifully carved
edge held up beautifully very well done
thank you sir
all right gentlemen you survived our
kill test and our strength test now the
sharpness test
test the sharpness of that blade and to
see if it still has an edge i'll be
cutting through these fish
a clean sharp blade should pass right
through those fish the dull blade is
gonna knock those fish out of the way or
give us a jagged torn cut collin you
ready yes sir okay
all right coming right off it's
definitely a sharp blade it cut very
nicely your handle is a bit on the fat
side
but it's definitely a cutter good job
thank you sir
daniel are you ready yes okay great
i feel that colin and i are still neck
and neck
i think that i've got a good edge on
but all you can do is hope for the best
at this point
all right daniel this blade is wicked
sharp
and those cuts
you can see they just blew right through
the fish my problem is this is
so small i had to fight to keep it in my
hand
these felissa often have a very small
handle but what saves that is having
that pummel keeping your hand from
coming off the back of that blade
it's an amazing cutter it's just very
difficult to hold on to
daniel collins there can only be one
forest and fire champion
and that champion is
colin
congratulations you are our new forged
and fire champion
daniel your sword didn't make the cut
daniel you gave us a beautiful blade and
a beautiful handle unfortunately you
made a weapon that we all agree was
difficult to control
so that balance that small handle it
made a weapon that couldn't be used at
speed at full force that's why we're
letting you go
daniel
please surrender your blade
i am disappointed of course that i
didn't win but i'm absolutely proud of
the work i did here if anything i think
that this fuels my fire to work harder
and do better
colin congratulations you are our new
forged and fire champion and that's the
title that comes with a check for 10
grand good job buddy
as far as your animal head pummel i'm
going to go ahead and say it's probably
an underdog
well colin please present your weapon to
the judges
will willis out here telling me i'm a
champion
can you believe
it champ
i can't believe it
fortune fire champion out here
the mccracker
the mccracker is a sickle-shaped weapon
with its cutting edge on the inside
curve of the blade it was notably used
by the azande tribe a dangerous clan
that invaded and conquered central
africa in the early 1800s with the help
of the macraca they took no prisoners
while defending their land and resources
the sword was often used in executions
to remove limbs and decapitate intruders
or enemies the azande's fatal and
terrorizing use of the mccracken is
highlighted in the game the deadliest
warrior
bladesmiths mccracker is a weapon used
by the zombie warriors get a sick like
blade and a tip representative of the
warriors manhattan
to see what kind of lethal damage your
weapon can do i will take your mccracken
and i'll deliver lethal blows on this
ballistic dummy craig you're up first
you ready yes sir let's do this all
right
[Music]
that's nasty you can mess somebody up
with that thing
this is one of the lightest swords i've
ever picked up
your tip over here was so sharp that it
went through and broke some bones your
edge on the inside curve allowed me to
lacerate deep
into his bowels right here but the most
important thing
it will kill
thank you
paul it's your turn i'm ready
[Music]
[Music]
well paul
we're one with speed this is power
because it's a lot heavier
it dug in deep into the chest cavity
on the lacerations on the blow it tends
to cut in and pull out heavily almost
lacerating
total front part of this ballistics
dummy overall your mccracker will kill
thank you
up next to strength test dave
gentlemen advantage of that sword was to
actually reach around the shield hitting
the man behind it so to test the
strength and durability of your blades
i'm going to strike these shields four
times with each of your weapons
this kind of wood can withstand
extremely brutal force so remember this
is not about what your sword does to the
shield what the shield does to your
swords craig you're up first are you
ready yes sir okay
all right i don't see
any nicks or damage
blade's still sharp
very nice well done thank you sir
good job
all right well you're up
let's do this
all right paul and i don't see any blade
damage and the edge is in good shape
i like the leather wrap on the handle
it's nice
so all in all nicely done thank you next
up is the sharpness test for that i'll
give you back to doug
the mccracker sword was used by the
zombie warriors for beheading their
prisoners to see how sharp your weapons
are we're gonna do a mock beheading over
here craig you up first you ready yes
sir let's do this all right
well craig on a vertical chop it was
easy to control my worry is about on a
horizontal chop or slice that the weight
would put pressure on my wrist
no issues whatsoever overall your blade
will cut thank you
paul you're up you ready yes sir let's
do this
watching craig's blade go through both
those watermelons you know now i'm
hoping that mine can do the same if my
blade can't at least match his stroke
for stroke probably going to go home
without the ten thousand dollars
okay paul the feel of your blade is a
little bit on the heavy side when you're
doing a horizontal slice it just hung up
on the watermelon
almost cutting all the way through
though but on the vertical slice
it just pulls you in and easily cuts all
the way through
your mccracker will cut
thank you
bladesmiths in just five days you've
done some exceptional work and your
blades perform very well but in this
arena of competition there can only be
one forged and fire champion and that
champion is
craig congratulations you are the
fortune fire champion
thank you all paul your blade did not
make the cut
paul you gave us a powerful blade but
you fell short on sharpness the bottom
line it underperformed the watermelons
and for that reason we have to let you
go
i accomplished what i wanted to do there
are guys on here that have made
thousands of blades and didn't make it
as far as i did
all right take care man first thing i do
when i get home is i'm gonna take a nap
it was a hell of a week i lost five
pounds
craig you are the forged and fire
champion and that's a title that comes
with a check for 10 000 congratulations
i'm quite surprised i never thought i'd
get this far why don't you present your
blade to the judges i certainly didn't
walk away with this paul put up a fight
but i could come there with the best
looking thing but if it doesn't perform
then you're out
the singisi
singizi are african throwing knives
crafted for over a hundred years by
blacksmiths in the mandera mountains in
central africa
they are typically about two feet long
featuring a double-edged blade with a
shape resembling the letter f
warriors often carry two or three singes
in combat sometimes attaching cords to
metal rings for easy retrieval at a
distance
as a throwing weapon its lethal range
was approximately 60 feet but it was
also wielded one-handed in conjunction
with the shield during close combat
today its extraordinary shape and design
make it a natural in ceremonial
applications and it carries great status
for its owner and high value in trade
bladesmiths this is the kill test i will
take your weapon and deliver killing
blows on this ram carcass ashley you're
up first you ready for this
oh yeah let's do this
[Music]
all right ashay first up when you pick
up the weapon it's comfortable the wrap
that you did gave me a very good grip on
the handle the point is sharp to
penetrate the carcass on its thrust and
it lacerates on the way out the back of
blade is sharp enough to cut all the way
through this carcass it's functional
it's sharp and most importantly
it will kill
thank you
all right leva you ready yes sir let's
do this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
nice job
thank you
right levi i like the kind of route you
put over here because it really feels
good on the hand it's almost like a
padding with a good grip on it
the stake's beautiful
your point
is so sharp
that on the first strike it penetrates
and almost lacerated the whole thing out
your outside curve on my fifth strike i
pretty much always cut all the way
through except it got caught on the bend
over here
but your weapon is sharp
it's scary
and it will kill
good job
bladesmiths welcome to our strength test
i want to do is take each of your
weapons and beat them repeatedly and
viciously into different points of this
shield
i said you're up first how you feeling
good let's do it all right
ugh
aside from the obvious you'd have a very
nice weapon here
the handle has got a good grip to it i
was able to get some really heavy duty
good penetrating strikes in there
but
obviously we have a problem it broke
when you put your little spike in here
these corners here are sharp
so even though it looks like a very good
heat treat you got a stress fracture in
there somewhere all that strength and
pressure came down that blade snapped
off right on that joint
ashay
your blade has suffered a catastrophic
failure and cannot continue with testing
but that doesn't mean that you're out of
this competition
levi
your blade needs to survive at least
nine strikes on this shield
are you ready indeed sir shea are you
ready oh yeah jay nielsen are you ready
oh yeah
let's do this gents
[Music]
blade bladesmiths this syngizi is
incredibly difficult to make and both of
you made very deadly weapons however you
both had problems in our strength test
ashay your blade failed after nine
strikes
levi unfortunately your blade suffered a
catastrophic failure on the first strike
against that shield
for that reason i have to ask you to
please leave the forge
i definitely proved why i came to prove
i wanted to be able to push myself
beyond my regular limits
good job
my family at home is definitely going to
be proud of me and i'm taking home
skills and knowledge that i didn't have
before i came here and that's definitely
a win for me
well ashay congratulations you are our
new fortune fire champion and that's a
title that comes with a check
10 000
good job
buddy this whole experience has changed
my life it's really made me strive to
become a better bladesmith
i'm not going to stop and no matter what
i'm going to keep forging ahead and
i want to be able to make the best
blades that have ever been made
the acrophina
kind of scared of it
the aquafina is a distinctive sword
hailing from the ashanti kingdom of west
africa around the 10th century a.d
initially used as a weapon of warfare
ashanti warriors brandished the sword in
one or both hands to deliver heavy
strikes in close quarters combat the
sword's curved blade and dumbbell-shaped
hilt were embedded with symbolic designs
known as a dynkra evoking ashanti
principles like courage valor or heroism
today the acrophina is a national symbol
of the modern-day ashanti city-state
carried by the king's royal emissaries
at prestigious ceremony
bladesmiths the aquafina was a weapon
used by the king's emissaries to
dispatch their enemies to see what kind
of lethal damage your weapon can do i
will deliver killing blows on this lamb
carcass
rock your up first you ready
yeah see what she
does ah
well brock
your sword bent
tight around corners now
but blades bend in combat it's
reassuring to hear him say that you know
oh well blades bend in battle it gives
me some reassurance that you know i'm
not just out of the game it's got a nice
feel to it i don't see any visible chips
on the edge
overall your weapon will kill
paige you're next i made my weapon to
cut the idea of hacking through heavy
bones with it
really has me nervous
[Music]
all right peach let's talk about the
balance of your blade it actually feels
good for chopping
your blade cut in deep
and it cut through the ribs
and those kinds of cuts
will kill
okay bladesmiths next up is a strength
test dave
gentlemen to test the strength of your
weapon i'll take two chops into these
pieces of bamboo now remember this isn't
about what your weapon does the bamboo
but what the bamboo does to your weapon
brock you're up first
no turning back
notice the shape there so we'll see how
we do after these cuts
[Applause]
all right so you take a look at that
we've actually straightened the blade
out quite a bit
it's very hard to line that blade up
when it's got that bend to it but it did
cut and
i'm not seeing any
damage to the edge
nicely done
paige
you are up next sir you ready yes sir
[Music]
you seem to have a issue developing
right there with a flake of metal
starting to come up things like that
start to give me pause about whether
that blade is going to hold up as we go
forward and testing
still sharp
all right i'm okay pushing this onto the
sharpness test
take case here
basements to see how sharp your
acrophina is i will take your sword and
deliver a slash across these ropes and
cargo straps let's see how many they can
cut through
rock you're up first
let's do it
ready
okay brock your blade was able to cut
through two ropes two of these ratchet
straps and almost to the fifth rope i
don't see that it's picked up any more
of a bend but overall your blade will
cut
pager next you ready yes sir
[Music]
all right basically we were able to cut
through at least eight strands over here
i don't see that you picked up any bend
on your blade here and overall your
blade
will cut
thank you good job bladesmiths you've
both done fantastic work but there can
only be one forged and fire champion and
that champion is
paige congratulations you are the forged
fire champion
brock
your weapon did not make the cut please
surrender your weapon
i came here to win but you know i'm
happy with what i did i learned a lot
from the experience thanks for providing
i don't think you should ever stop
challenging yourself it's back to the
forge making new things every day so i'm
excited to get back to that
paige congratulations you are the forged
and fire champion and we'll be receiving
a check for ten thousand dollars i feel
him right now i'm very relieved i'm very
happy
i'm a metal geek and i've never won
anything like this what forged in fire
pretty much forced me to do is step way
the heck outside of my comfort zone i'd
like to thank brock for being a worthy
opponent he gave me a fair run for the
money he really made me work for this
one
you